Hello. This is Sonny calling from a very rainy Houston, Texas.
Radiolab is supported by dash digital cash dash allows you to send any amount of
money using a highly secure peer to peer network.
Skip the bank entirely and control your money your way.
Dash is digital cash. For more information,
visit dash.org forward slash radio lab.
You're listening to radio lab from public radio, w.
N. Y. S. E. N. N. P. R.
What we have over the criminal is the criminal actually thinks he's destroyed.
All the evidence is never oldest, right?
[inaudible]
ever, ever, ever. Never.
This is Lou Garcia originally retired from New York city fire department as the
chief fire Marshall,
so I've spent 25 years of my life looking at fires and investigating the causes
before. How many pairs do you think you've seen? Both
tens of thousands of fires. You'll have seen 10 years of that. Absolutely.
You'll, you'll hear yourself. Yeah.
When he tells me his story there was this a true story?
I'm not going to get too many details about it,
but there was a fire in an area of New York City who was in an apartment
building in the south Bronx. As I pulled up to this building,
the fire was already over with Lou Gatto.
There were people in the street and we're questioning people. People are saying,
well, in the apartment where the fire was, there was this brave guy.
Somehow he'd gotten in there and he was pouring water trying to get the fire
out. This guy was really something, you know, and he's, and he's,
he's the hero right now. Everybody's telling me what a hero he is.
Everything that we're saying in the street about this man was wrong.
[inaudible]
so he walks into the apartment, he looks around,
he knows right away where the fire started. Now how, how well,
you just look at the fire pattern
[inaudible]
and you could tell that the fire started first of all,
in the bedroom with a mattress mattress.
The mattress now matches go up. If you put a match to it. Really? I mean,
don't you have to put like gasoline on the mattress? No, no, no.
You just put a match onto a match mattress and it will catch fire. Yes.
If you hold a bit longer. Yeah.
And he also knew that the mattress had been placed upright against the wall.
You could tell by the five pounds that was standing on it. Wow.
He can even know what position the mattress was in. Yes, absolutely. Believe me.
So he meets the woman whose apartment this is, she shows up and he says,
there's so, do you know this fellow who is putting out the fire? She's, yes.
As a matter of fact, I do. It just so happens that you used to live with me,
but I kicked him out and he still had a key, by the way.
And she knows, says, I have a new boyfriend.
Right?
So Garcia naturally goes and finds the hero. All right,
so now I'm questioning this up. I said, by the way, did you buy that mattress?
And he said, yes, I did. And you weren't sleeping anymore with someone else.
Could be in the mattress in your place. I says, yeah,
we should have the boyfriend. I said, boy, I'd be pissed. How of the course,
like four or $500 you said no more than that. It was like 800 off. I said,
so now she is screwing somebody else on the mattress you bought.
I would be pissed. I said, you know, if it was me, if I were in your place,
I would want this mattress to burn. I was probably standing on end.
I would take matches, matches, and I would put it to the, to the mattress.
That's what I would do and in fact,
I'm an expert on fires and I know that's what you did. You really did do it.
Yeah, you can talk about it. I don't blame you.
I mean at least you tried to put it out,
but that'll work in your favor in court. And he looks at me. He says, well,
you're not so smart. I said, wine. He goes, I used the lighter.
Yeah.
Oh, you're right. I'm not
[inaudible].
Okay, so that was an easy one. We're going to have some harder ones coming up.
Yup. Point is the whole hour. We're going to be addressing the same problem.
We'll walk into one situation after another and discover that something is not
right here. That's right. Something's not right with my son. What do I do?
Something's not right with my pancreas. What do I do?
Something's not right with the very phrase.
Something is not right because it presumes that I know what's right and maybe I
don't have we confused you enough? Well,
there's a whole lot of abnormal things coming your way. This is Radiolab.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Quilt. Stay with us.
Okay, so this first story is about, uh,
delivering a diagnosis comes to us from producer Lulo Koski.
It's about two doctors. You start with that phrase,
something's not right here and end up going on a crazy adventure after a cure
for a deadly disease, which is that pancreatic cancer. Oh, that's not good.
It is. Look the most deadly cancer.
This is the one that people have nightmares about. Why you mean it's deadly?
How like, well, if it's rare but it's deadly, it's the one where you know you,
something's wrong. You'd go to the doctor and they say,
you have six months to live. Wow. Is it that fast? It, it usually is that fast.
Um, how'd you find this out? I found this up because my friend Amy, um, said,
I've got a friend named Dr. Terry Brenton all.
She made a big scientific discovery and you should go to her
press conference. This will be amazing. Go. And I go to the press,
male friends.
It's just a tremendous pleasure to be here today.
Press conferences are kind of never amazing and I hope to one unfold a story for
you. I hope it will capture your attention.
It's a fascinating story and I heard this incredible story about 10 years ago.
One morning, a 40 year old guy came into my clinic,
Mr x just finishing mine, very healthy looking.
And he comes into my clinic and he says,
I'm worried I'm going to get pancreatic cancer,
that I'm going to get the curse in my family. It was like,
good gooby what are you talking about? And he said, well, in my family,
my father got pancreatic cancer,
my grandfather and my four uncles and my three cousins. Wow.
Four uncles, three cousins, father, grandfather, all die of pancreatic cancer.
And this guy was sure he was next in line.
His uncles and his father looked like the healthiest people in the world.
Six months later they're dead. He was terrified.
He came to me as a act of desperation.
I mean, it's not a feeling, I guess they're not. Maybe I know or you know.
But what happened when you walked in was like Terri,
she knew exactly how he felt. You can't even process anything.
You're just like almost in a trance. She'd gone through that before,
completely and utterly alone.
She was diagnosed with breast cancer when she was 34 it's a sense of falling.
It's truly a sense of falling.
The world slides away from you and you literally,
it's almost like it disappears from underneath you. When she got the news,
the first thing her doctor did, he was a friend of hers,
pulled out the whiskey and put it on the table.
She had a shower, which I was like, thank God he did that.
I'm not good. Quite honestly, we're gonna fight this name.
You are not alone. That's all I needed to hear.
And so when she was sitting there with, with patient x, she know exactly.
They would just say, you have to step forward.
You can step back and just [inaudible]
[inaudible]
I was young then and so I felt, look,
I fixed this thing. I'll take that on. I can help you.
I don't care how horrible it's what happens next.
So Terry runs back to her office and office, she shares with another doctor,
Mary Bronner. I'm Mary Brunner, I'm a pathologist. So I was like, Mary,
Mary says you won't believe this. This guy, Mr x,
walk into my office and he has this outrageous, this crazy family histories.
Horrible problem was floored.
Terry had never heard that pancreatic cancer could be inherited and families,
they'd never heard of anything like that. Terry comes in and she's like,
I've got to help this guy. I have to figure out what's making these people sick.
And Mary, I need your help. And, and Mary, what did she say? Well,
she's a pathologist. So what does it mean to be a pathologist? Well, she's,
she's the person who physically does the diagnosis.
When your surgeon does an operation on you or your internist takes a biopsy of
you,
they send that tissue to me and I make it into glass slides to look at under the
microscopes.
So she spends her time looking at tiny pieces of Terry's patients,
smeared on little slots. I,
I love the emotional distance that you have in pathology. You're, you know,
a step removed from the misery and it makes it so much easier
for me to handle it. Does she interact with patients? Almost never.
Terry was right up against in Missouri and she was just relaying the story to
me.
But I can sit very comfortably at my microscope and be very objective and just
look at the tissue and decide where the cancer is because I don't know these
patients. So you're like, I gotta go do this.
Come with me as she usually does.
How did you decide that Mary should join you?
She's my science partner. That's it.
And I have been the cat.
I usually [inaudible] so they decided in order to help this guy,
they need to go to where his family is.
We drove across the mountains of Washington state.
[inaudible] dry. They wanted to get the family together.
What it means to treat Zach. They make them draw their blood,
look at their blood to see if there's something in there that's making all these
people sick. And
we arrive at the little tiny town in eastern Washington,
a little town called Elma. And then they didn't even have, they're so small,
they don't have a single medical facility. So in order to do the blood drop,
we basically had to use the subway sandwich shop in town.
Why, why subway would have great sandwiches.
One of the family members worked there and asked the boss if,
if the family could all come and these doctors could come and draw their blood
and could we use the shop as the meeting, right.
All I remember is walking in and thinking this is small.
So we've set up a little corner booth with our box of blood drawing supplies and
they sort of came in waves, uncles, cousins, nieces and nephews.
And they brought their kids. He's filled that subway sandwich shop.
How many in all?
About 30 it was funny cause they hadn't seen each other a long time are like,
oh my God, see you in 10 years. It's like, wow,
you guys only live like five miles a day.
We'd bring them over to our little tiny booth and we didn't introduce ourselves.
I'm Terry Brenton or Mary Brian or GI doctor or amnesty surgical oncologist.
The purpose of our work today is that we are trying to find the cancer gene that
causes the disease in your family. With your permission today,
we'd like to take a small blood sample. It's about the size of two tablespoons.
You will not get any results back from this blood test.
I want to be really clear about that. It's all for us to try and find the gene.
I can't even promise that. We'll definitely find that gene.
Here's your sandwich and now me have some blood.
As we were waiting for most of the family to show up,
Terry and I were sitting in this one booth with one of the family members who we
had already identified as having the disease. He was young,
he was in his thirties and I like it think was you have a time bomb,
okay
inside your body [inaudible]
and then this little boy comes running into the subway sandwich shop just like
runs up to this guy that we're talking to this patient to family x. Well his,
his arms around his daddy's neck and kisses him and Andy and all I could think
was, oh my God, this beautiful little child,
he has 50% chance.
Okay I in this hideous disease and I was so upset about that.
I was just so torn apart inside but I couldn't really, you know,
start balling right there that wouldn't have been professional.
They held it together until we were driving home and,
and I was telling Terry how I'll say it,
I was about that little boy and how it just really hit me and she said,
Oh hey, don't worry about him. He's adopted.
You have to remember Mary doesn't come face to face with patients very often.
It's not something a pathologist does very frequently.
Pathologists have the,
I don't even know if I want to tell you this is sort of like [inaudible]
yes. The black side of pathology.
Black humor to get you through or yeah, really black humor, you know,
we'll say things like, um,
somebody better tell this patient not to buy the big tube of toothpaste.
Terry's laughing, but that's why we do it because it's so horrible.
I spent an afternoon with Mary going through slides,
looking at pancreatic tissue, three trying to figure out like, you know,
if this person has cancer or not. Dozens of patients.
Now this is another case with a terrible,
terrible case and that's when I really kind of got it. Like why she'd want to
keep herself distant. Oh, this cancer is even worse than the last one.
This person, if they can shit,
go to a beautiful place on planet earth and just stay there
till it's over. Well, what happened after subway though? I mean,
were they able to, you know, figure out what's causing this thing? Well,
once they got the blood, they worked on it for about five years, five years.
You know, they went chromosome by chromosome,
collaborated with all these other researchers.
And at the end of the day they discovered that the thing that causes familial
pancreatic cancer comes down to a mistake.
One little mistake on one one molecule molecule.
I know it comes down to one tiny molecule. Yes.
So our discovery is, uh,
we're titling it pallet and mutation causes familial pancreatic cancer and
suggests a new cancer mechanism. So they write a paper.
I have a press conference of all I want to acknowledge and celebrate.
[inaudible]
so in the end, do they, do they find a cure? Well, no, not yet.
They're working on it. Can they at least, um, test for it now? Well,
they can test, but it's what, you know,
most pancreatic cancer isn't hereditary like this.
This is actually a small subset.
So where does that leave Mary and Terry? I mean, where are they now?
Mary's really glad the research phase
is over and that she doesn't have to be with patients anymore. Terry
knows they have more work to do and they can't really give up,
but she's really tired and thinks about it a lot. You know,
the stakes are so high in this eye. Sometimes it's almost unbearable.
Sometimes I think I should quit. Yeah, totally.
I've talked to Mary about it, but you know what?
I know she'll never stop doing it. Right. Terry?
[inaudible]
sometimes it's just too much
too.
Mary and I love to garden. So sometimes you know,
we think about being landscape architects and then the worst thing that does is,
oh, I killed the bush. They were like, you lose, or you killed the bush.
[inaudible] [inaudible] you
thanks to the little Kelsey for reporting that story.
The next story concerns a dad and his little boy.
There's something about this little boy that is not quite right,
but there's something about the dad that doesn't want to say.
So that's coming up in about a minute. I'm Jed Abu Rod and I'm Robert Krulwich.
Radiolab will continue.